one of the most overlooked accessories
in gaming
is mousepads over the years mousepads
haven't only gotten larger but companies
have started making them with new
materials and as esports have become
more popular players have started to
discover that certain pads actually suit
their playstyles or even their games
better than others so how did mousepads
come to be and how do they differ it
sometimes feels as if there's hundreds
of options out there for us gamers so
how do you know which one is supposed to
suit you
well
let's find out
[Applause]
so back in 1968 there was an engineer by
the name of douglas engelbart who held a
conference in san francisco that is now
referred to
as the mother of all demos initially
everyone expected to listen to my boy
douglas talk about the research that he
conducted at his augmentation research
center at stanford but instead of just
talking about it he surprised everyone
by actually showing them a demo now this
demo didn't just feature some
old ass computer and keyboard
no this marked the very first time that
a mouse was actually shown
to the public there's don andrews hand
in mineral part
and in a second we'll see the screen
that he's working and the way the
tracking spot moves in conjunction
with movements of that mouse
i don't know why we call it a mouse
sometimes i apologize it started that
way
and we never did change it so it's safe
to say that the homie doug
blew a couple of minds that day you just
put my [ __ ] mind
but there was still one thing missing
from his setup
douglas
needed a mouse pad now luckily for him
herman miller designer jack kelly
designed the first mouse pad just one
year later in 1969 and from then on
everyone started using them over the
course of the 1970s ball mice dominated
the market so anyone who had a computer
and a mouse usually opted to use a soft
mouse pad alongside it but as the 80s
rolled around optical mice became
increasingly popular and because of
their use of image sensors to track
motion
mouse pads weren't exactly required the
only problem with optical mice is that
they can't be used on reflective or
transparent surfaces like glass so
depending on your setup pads were
sometimes a must luckily in the late 90s
this problem was solved with the release
of laser mice which performed much
better on said surfaces so at that point
you didn't really need a mouse pad
until people started to game as pc
gaming became more mainstream in the
early 2000s
counter-strike competitors in particular
were still having issues with their
generic mouse pads since normal pads
require cleaning in order to give you
consistent control over your mouse steel
series eventually saved the fps world in
2001 with a glass pad called the ice mat
and later the ever goated qck for a new
generation of mice demanded a new kind
of mousepad we tested 751 surfaces to
create qck a combination of microwoven
cloth and natural rubber that gives you
flawless mouse control and all-day
comfort while fps games like quake and
counter-strike dominated the market in
europe and the americas rts esports i.e
starcraft became massive in south korea
as starcraft's esports scene continued
to grow in popularity many competitors
began rocking higher dpis because gaming
branded mice supported them and since a
lot of pros were using above average
dpis
small mouse pads were standard fare back
then but as tack fps's like
counter-strike grew more and more larger
pads became more popular due to the slow
and methodical nature of counter-strike
many competitors gravitated towards
lower sensitivities and since you're
physically required to move your mouse
long distances on low sensitivity it
made sense that competitors wanted
bigger pads rather than just using small
wrist movements to control their cursors
many players began placing their entire
elbows on their desks in order to better
control their movements and naturally
the mousepad market was forced to cater
to them nowadays almost every popular
mousepad is available in a variety of
different sizes so depending on your
sensitivity the possibilities are
endless help you can even get pads that
cover your entire desk if you want but
over time it wasn't just the shape and
size that was changing it was the
materials that were being used to
produce these pads here's the thing
though
i'm a boomer who uses a boomer pad and i
don't know anything about this carbon
fiber glass business so i'm going to ask
my good friend colton to come in
and do all the research on the zoomer
pads and
teach us about them and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
so
i've got good news and bad news
the bad news first well we're going to
be breaking out that physics textbook
from a few episodes ago
the good news
well
at least i think physics is cool so
sucks to suck
no the real good news is that it's high
school physics so most of you should be
just fine why physics well at the heart
of the mouse pad discussion is the
coefficient of friction and
understanding this concept can actually
help you better understand your choices
of mouse pad material there are two
pieces to the coefficient of friction
static friction which refers to the
amount of force required to take an
object like a mouse from stationary to
moving that force is always higher than
the second half kinetic friction which
is the amount of resistance between your
mouse pad and mouse while it's already
in motion as you already know different
surfaces are going to give you different
friction values which make it easier or
harder to move your mouse around but
that begs the obvious question wouldn't
you just want to make this number as low
as possible well as the kids on the
magic school bus discovered we do need
at least some friction to make
controlled motion
how much though is mostly up to you
whether it's microfiber or leather with
all manner of different core materials
all the way up to solid mouse pads made
out of glass or even wood you can get as
custom as you or your wallet are willing
to get am i simplifying the science a
fair bit here
yes but if you're curious about actually
measuring the static friction of your
mouse pad then you're gonna need a
little trigonometry and i'm not trying
to scare anyone away with that [ __ ] and
the sine of theta over cosine theta
equals tangent theta therefore
the coefficient of static friction
between the book and the incline is
equal to the tangent of the incline
angle right before the book starts to
slide and the mouse pad is actually only
half of the equation but i'm going to
let dimitri deal with most skates and at
the end of the day how easy your mouse
pad is to move across isn't even the
only factor you want to worry about you
are eventually going to have to clean
the thing and the softer more porous
pads will prove much more challenging in
that regard so you
yes you sitting at your desk right now
with a crumbly snack in your hand stop
eating at your desk like some kind of
wild animal please
and that was the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about because you can
buy mice that weigh virtually nothing or
ones with you know modular weight
editions you can find one that feels
exactly the way you want it to on top of
that the mouse skate market has gone
absolutely nuclear over the past few
years for a long time most mice
typically shipped with teflon mouse
gates but if you give any sort of [ __ ]
about gaming peripherals then there's a
very good chance that you've at least
heard of glass mousekates aftermarket
skates have become insanely popular and
they too can give you a much faster feel
than traditional teflon skates
at the expense of some control and
stopping power as you can see i'm having
a pretty rough time here i mean aim is
seriously just all over the place and it
looks like my first time ever playing
with a gaming mouse when i say that
there is absolutely zero stopping power
or friction on these things i really
really mean it in fact the only way that
i'm able to control and stop the mouse
is by using my hand contact with the
mouse pad itself so aiming scenarios
where you need to flick and stop on a
small target they feel almost impossible
because i'm so used to having that
feedback and traction from the mouse pad
and helping me stop on that target
alright so now that you know the history
of mouse pads and have some rough idea
of what all the different kinds do it's
time that we got to that pressing
question
what kind do the pros use well although
there isn't one singular god pad that
every top competitor is rocking there
are some very popular options out there
that many of your favorite players do in
fact swear by if you are a cs stan like
myself
then you've definitely at least heard of
the logitech g640 and of course the
zowie gsr which i use both of which are
solid control pads that are great for
slower paced games like tax shooters but
i wouldn't necessarily recommend them if
you're into battle royales or arena
shooters where you often rely on a lot
of tracking the glorious fire pad is
also a good option but it is slightly
smaller so if you play on low sends then
it might not be the best option for you
one last notable mention has to go to
the steel series qck though which we did
mention earlier in the video although
the first iteration of this thing came
out nearly 20 years ago it is still one
of the most popular mouse pads used by
pros across multiple esports lastly i
want to talk briefly about artisan pads
although they have a pretty high price
tag these mouse pads are some of the
highest quality products you will ever
see they don't wear out nearly as fast
as other pads so you won't have to clean
them as often and whether you're looking
for a fast pad or a control pad they
have options for anyone niall actually
did a review on his artisan heian last
month so make sure to check that out if
you haven't already mousepads may seem
kind of
simple but
they're actually really sophisticated
and they've come a long way from the
original rubber pads used with ball mice
to glass pads to these new artisan
things
the possibilities are endless hell even
if you don't care about the feel of it
and you just want an rgb wireless
charging one then you might even
sacrifice performance just to fit a
certain aesthetic do you want an anime
inspired mouse pad
certainly wouldn't be my first choice
but
hey do you my dude there are some pretty
wild options out there if you don't
especially care about the quality of the
pad and look it can take a lot of time
to stumble upon your personal favorite
mouse pad but when you do
it is a great feeling
and it will actually make a way bigger
difference than you think
throughout the 1970s ball mice done
throughout the night like so great about
saying ball my stuff
throughout the 70s ball mice dominate
i can't save almost dude
throughout the 70s
i gotta get through it dude throughout
the seven
all right sip of water and then we pout
flowers
oh it's been a long [ __ ] day all
right